imaginez des aliments sans lait sans eux
sans sucre sans sel sans gras sans
gluten c'est ce que l'on voit de plus en
plus sur les tablettes des épiceries
j'ai fait que ça peut louer une
quinzaine d'années il fait un ancien a
pris son envol cette recherche
d'authenticité mais surtout de neige ou
de nos bidouillage avec ma nourriture
la fondation des maladies du coeur avec
son programme nous défendre et et a eu
une grande influence sur les légumes en
attendant du sang ce sims en cela
notamment parce que ça a été la première
fois pour nous faisait vraiment prendre
conscience du lien direct qu'il n'y a
entre certains nutriments et des effets
négatifs sur la santé
les consommateurs sont plus soucieux de
l'importance d'une saine alimentation de
l'environnement alors on voit des
allégations se multiplier sur les
emballages des produits
nous avons demandé à isabelle marquis
nutritionniste de nous aider à s'y
retrouver
ça peut référer à des nutriments
à des ingrédients à des allergènes à des
techniques et l'ombre est fait référence
à toutes sortes de choses proposition
effets sur la santé et fabrication
alouettes c'est que les consommateurs
doutent beaucoup de l'industrie
agroalimentaire et conséquemment da il
cherche à se structurer à choisir des
produits qui sont probablement moins
nocif pour eux à la recherche ces codes
visuels qui leur dit dans ce produit là
j'ai pas besoin de m'inquiéter rassurant
quand on a des allergies d intolérance
ou pour des raisons de santé
mais c'est aussi un outil marketing et
malgré la réglementation il y a beaucoup
de confusion ce qui est pas clairement
ce que c'est c'est qu'est-ce qu'on ait
fait de mon passé exactement comme
message est ce que on veut sous-entendre
que le maïs est nocif pour la santé
ce n'est pas un allergène en soi donc
c'est sûr qu'il n'a pas la même valeur
ou la même consonance que le sang a
lâché pied juste à côté présenté de la
sorte un porte à confusion souvent il ya
ce raccourci qui est effectué entre le
moins est le meilleur alors souvent à
défaut d'être cas pas dévaluer lequel
des produits est le meilleur mais on
fait cette espèce de raccourci
intellectuel entre 6 au port tel ou tel
truc de danse ça doit donc
nécessairement meilleur pour moi
- de tous et surtout moins de sucre on
met clairement de l'avant le fixe et
sans sucre ajouté
or ça peut suggérer qu'il n'y a pas de
sucre du tout dans le produit mais
évidemment des fruits en contiennent
personnellement mais ce qui est encore
plus particulier dans ce cas ci c'est
que le produit a été édulcorée booster
humanité substituts de sucre donné pas
moins sucré il est juste sucré
autrement on affiche beaucoup sans sucre
mais le défi c'est de la confusion entre
le sucre ce qui ajouté le suc
transformer si ce système là est pas
clair on ne résout pas le problème
initial
qu'est ce qu'on peut penser par exemple
d'un biscuit comme ça ici où on peut
lire sans sirop de maïs à forte teneur
en fructose 7 en argent ce krach qui est
préférable d'éviter parce que c'est
ultra transformer mais ultimement il
faut pas comprendre de ça que ce produit
n'est pas sucré
ça reste très secret le consommateur ne
fait pas nécessairement la différence si
la marque est rendu à apposer ce logo là
dessus c'est qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'autres choses dont il peut être fier
sur son emballage on insiste sur un
ingrédient qui n'est pas présent à
l'origine dans l'aliment ce qui
contrevient à la réglementation comme
par exemple des tomates sans gluten ya
jamais eu lui tellement fort et y en
aura jamais non plus l'entrée du gluten
je pense qu est ce qui est surtout à
retenir c'est que c'est d'abord et avant
tout une déclaration d'allergènes
ça n'est pas du tout là pas du tout un
gage de santé du produit parfois on
cherche seulement une façon de se
déculpabiliser le nom la façon dont on
fait la présentation du produit
les mentions du sang tout ça est
volontairement produits pour me donner
l'impression de déculpabilisante que la
collation n'est pas si mauvaise pour moi
ici on voit sans cuisson sont produits
laitiers sans gluten sans sucre ajouté
donc on ajoute même sans cuisson comme
étant un avantage laissant cuisson le
cru ce qu'on veut nous communiquer en
réalité on retrouve la réponse dans le
nom du produit c'est à dire que ce sont
des bouchers cru le cru peut être un
argument marketing parce que c'est une
communauté de gens qui mangent truc est
en croissance c'est directement en lien
avec le
le végétalisme l'alimentation ses traits
identitaires
les gens sont fiers de la façon dont il
mange et se définissent beaucoup par
leur alimentation
on recherche le petit symbole qui nous
dit ce postulat il est juste pour